- I did it.
And I'm comfortable and I travel.
It's a good life. It's such a good life.
(gentle music)
I'm 70.
- I am 70.
- 71 years old.
- Best years of my life.
- 70 is not bad. (chuckles)
- I feel I'm right in
between feeling really old
and still feeling young enough
to be able to do the
things that I wanna do.
(gentle music)
- I wanted a position that
there weren't many people
in that position that looked like me.
When I bid for the position, she was like,
I don't know if you can do this.
I looked around the department
and I saw the people doing
and I said, well aren't those
humans sitting at the desk?
I'm human so I can do it too.
The rest is history as I
say, that was 31 years ago.
- I married the same person three times
and so I put my children through
some very unpleasant experiences.
- At the age of 61,
I was diagnosed with a
rare and aggressive cancer.
I definitely felt my
mortality's on this balancing,
doing the things that
I believe in and enjoy
with not knowing how much longer
I'm gonna be able to do it.
- With the divorce and
going back and forth
for three times, okay I
wasn't ready to give up on it.
But there came a time where
I needed to give up on it.
You have to forgive yourself.
(gentle music)
- The city was trying to condemn
this low income residence.
We're able to re-habit.
What was nice for me was
seeing this first generation
Japanese immigrant woman,
when she moved back into
her apartment, was in tears.
- I feel like I was a
much better grandmother
than I was mother.
I know when my daughter
moved, I spent that hour
crying because I wasn't going to have
my granddaughter there and my grandson.
And that's when I
reduced my hours at work.
I said I'm not gonna be a
grandma that they don't know.
- Being a coordinator,
I tell them, you know,
let me know if it's not a
good fit and I'll change you.
So one little boy, the
tutor wanted to be changed
'cause she said he asks
too many questions.
So I took him.
And when I took him, it was that I found
that he was just very intelligent.
He was very inquisitive.
But really got to me though was that
one week when we came back,
he came in the door and said,
I'm a genius, I'm a genius.
And I was like tears, like now.
He said I got 100% on my spelling test.
And I thought that was just phew,
I did that. I helped him do that.
(gentle music)
The misconception that so
many young people have is that
when you grow old, everything
... you lose stuff.
You don't.
Your mind and your desires and your drives
stay the same, they're there.
It's just that your body
can't fulfill (chuckles)
those wishes.
But I went zip lining at 55 years old.
And I mean it was an adventure.
I was mature age but just go for it.
- You know in the night before my surgery,
where they did not know
what they were gonna find.
They knew it was a large tumor.
Some of the things I said,
you know I've got a good life.
It's a life of purpose.
It's a life of doing
the things I believe in.
- I don't have a bucket list anymore.
I may have something tomorrow
that I never thought,
oh maybe I wanna do that.
I'm living my bucket list daily.
I'm doing what I wanna do right now.
- When one dies, you know,
you don't look at the date of birth
and the date when they died.
But you look at the dash in between
and that's what's important,
is what did they do during that life?
Don't let the passions
that fueled you (chuckles)
when you were younger die out.
- Go boldly into the future
and boldly into your maturity
because it's a wonderful thing.
It's life cycle, it's wonderful.
Embrace it. It's cool, I'm happy.
(gentle music)